en peu de temps les journées de sept
propriétaires de centres de la petite
enfance sont devenus très chargé depuis
l'implantation des maternelles 4 à
joindre les deux bouts est devenu
complexe pour donna buckland elle est
incapable d'augmenter le salaire de ses
employés pour les retenir
je remplace pendant les pauses repas et
passent plus de temps avec les enfants
pendant ce temps je n'arrive pas à faire
mes tâches de directrice contrairement
au québec
ici ce sont des éducatrices de la petite
enfance qui doivent enseigner la
maternelle 4 en dévalisant ici le bassin
d'employés qualifiés déjà considérés
comme des denrées rares et les
éducatrices comme king conrad trouve le
système scolaire très attrayant les
quarts de travail sont plus courts on a
plus de vacances et de meilleurs
avantages sociaux marco les enseignants
eux aussi veulent mettre la main sur ces
emplois syndicat des enseignants de la
nouvelle écosse a déposé un grief contre
le ministère d'éducation
les gouvernements il ferme le cursus
scolaire de la prématernelle doit être
enseignée par des éducatrices
c'est un programme d'éducation
préscolaire basé sur le jeu ce n'est pas
ce que les enseignants apprennent dans
leur formation
un apprentissage basé sur le jeu donc
comme dans les centres de la petite
enfance d'un avocat n est encore plus
perplexe
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement n'a
pas plutôt investi dans le système déjà
en place le réseau à plus de 400
garderie qui offre de bons services
c'est triste de voir comment ils ont
fait ça et combien ça a perturbé tout le
monde l'implantation de ces classes se
fait sur quatre ans en 2020 tous les
enfants devraient y avoir accès le
déploiement trop rapide selon certains
mais pour le ministre de l'éducation il
ya péril en la demeure
alors que sa province est la seule au
pays où le taux de pauvreté chez les
enfants augmente ici seulement un enfant
sur quatre avaient accès à des services
d'apprentissage préscolaire réglementé
ah oui nous savons combien l'éducation
est importante pour le développement des
jeunes enfants
mais c'est une option encore incomplète
les parents qui choisissent d'y envoyer
leurs enfants doivent maintenant assumer
les repas et ont quand même besoin de
services de garde payant la maternelle 4
ans et de 8h30 à 14h30
la plupart des parents besoins du
service de garde avant et après ces
heurts le gouvernement est conscient de
la pression que son grand chantier mais
sur tout le réseau
nous voulons recruter 2000 éducatrices
de la petite enfance forme et qui n'ont
pas poursuivi dans cette voie
nous allons aussi offrir plus de
programmes de formation
le ministère doit même faire appel au
centre de la petite enfance pour y
ouvrir des classes de maternelle quatre
ans et ce témoin les gars des wan si
donna comprend l'importance du programme
elle est très inquiète pour ses
garderies tous les ans 85 enfants de 4
ans intègre nos centres si nous perdons
une portion de ses enfants
et si nous ne pouvons pas retenir les
éducatrices nous allons devoir fermer
des centres
déjà certaines ont dû mettre la clé sous
la porte ici et les à céret radio canada
à halifax